Matt King just got engaged a few months
ago and he had an engagement party a
couple days ago and I ran into you there
I was a little drunk I'll be very honest
it was very busy we're running around
and I'm running to the door because our
Uber's there or something and I passed
by Kelsey acting like we're best friends
I've met her baby twice ten words to her
total I go hi
and walk away and I was like why did I
do that
I wanted to be like a high Gorge like hi
girl and she said hi
she was like
her face was just and I said I'm sorry
so if you could just tell her I'm sorry
I don't know why I did that yeah yeah so
he did say that she was like Britney
jump scared me at the party yeah yeah
she walked away yeah I was just in a
normal conversation
literally was she was like hi